I'll dress for the weather degrees now
like 15 we've got a very special guest
in the studio this morning Joe Rogan
what's up Joe I just showed these people
these lovely people
one guy one cop the worst that I've ever
seen in my whole entire life
yeah I'm doing stand-up at the funny
bone tonight and at the southern theater
tomorrow night the southern theater
tomorrow night I'm actually filming a
comedy special for Spike TV one hour's
batch of respite City tomorrow the
southern theater please get us mr. Joe
thank you the fuck is going on my
friends so I'm very excited to be here
in Columbus I'm doing a Spike TV special
tomorrow night it was nice to have that
warm-up set in just loosen up get all
the kinks out get rid all the nerves and
just the next day I just barbell
you broke it just not working this
toilets too low for me
okay Hollywood expose notice having tell
Joe to re-enter the car so we have to
drive around
Joey what happened on the plane there
was like a cop or something
the chair was twisted when I took the
thing out the back to prevent me first
class the little fish
mine was twisted so she put the meal
down so he's talking to his little buddy
oh my god did you see and I go excuse me
excuse me excuse me as he's going back
to sports the fucking fool I'm like
excuse me and the guy heard Joe you know
people he is like from Orange County
good thank you
like oh excuse me I finally just push
the fucking thing push the fucking thing
I'm just wishing the goddamn meal that
was the end of that so ate my meal it
was eating at me on Herman - humming -
so she goes up closer to the back of
stretch bring him back to things from
the back taking him up she picks up my
track out of pique I got the weave in my
ball sack though that's fucking you
kicking right I could smell is kicking
the breath tab is going off Hey -
cookies or second floors flood
this is planet earth with you shooting
towards it and your logo sort of left in
the air so like a smoke on trail and the
title of the show Joe Rogan comedy
special talking monkeys not too long at
the bar 15 yeah they're rowdy
like me now I'm in the mix
where positive image video that's what
this place headquarters world
headquarters is ignoring that this is
the motherfucking man he directs all the
UFC Wired's he directs all the UFC's he
directs the UFC is unleashed all that
bullshit anything UFC all-access this is
the fucking guy and I'm so directing my
Spike TV program